شاب سعودي شغوف بالتصوير وخصوصا صور
الاكشن حول فناء منزله كموقع التصوير وحول
غرفته معرضا للوحاته التي تحكي كل منها
قصه مختلفه
الشاب السعوديه فواز الزهراني المهتم
بتصوير الاكشن السينمائي حققت اعمالهم
ملايين المشاهدات عبر من الصوت التواصل
الاجتماعي وحول منزله معرض لصوره التي
تحقيق قصصا مختلفه كالصوره التي تبقى
فكرتها من مشهد في فيلم
من انا صغيره وانا احب العامل الحرب
الحب الافلام اللي فيها حرف حب احب الشيء
هذا الشيء انا احبك
[موسيقى]
عندك
فيلم امريكي يتوقع الاغنيه كانت تتكلم عن
جندي رايح
الاغنيه تقول له تعال اللي هي حبيبتي
سويتها بطريقه ثانيه
واصدقائه المقربين يظهر العمل في صورته
النهائيه الجميله
ملك
الحوش هذا جهزته تجهيز كامل بحيث انه يكون
موقع حرب عشان اقدر اصور فيه الصور فيديو
سويت فيه عندك
شك شكائر سويت اللوكيشن كامل بحيث انه
يكون هذا المكان
واستغليت النقطه هذه في الصور بحيث انه
انا في الصوره اشيل الخلفيه ولكن التضاريس
والاشياء اللي حول الموديل اللي بيتصور
تكون حقيقيه يعني
[موسيقى]
ما يرحم
الزهراني تخصص في صور الاكشن لكنه واجه
عقبات خاصه عبر منصه تيك توك تجاه هذا
النوع من التصوير ما جعله يسلك خط
الرومانسيه في بعض اعماله
عشان الموضوع
السلاح والدم فانت اعاني من ناحيه الحضر
الحساب احيانا الفيديو ثلاث مليون
الثاني على القلب محظور الحساب في سلاح
وفي دم وهي السياسه الحين ماشيين عليها
يعني اضطريت انه اغير الجيش بعض
الفيديوهات
رومانسي مع انه اصحابي فواز يسوي رومانسي
على شيء جديد بس كنت تطلع صوره مختلفه
برده عن همم الصوره العاديه
تيجي نقراه
اليوم وتقول انت انت
مواهب السعوديه
للمواهب واحتضان الفنون والاهتمام بها
محمد الزهراني العربيه جدا